what's going on guys this is rob and i
just woke up and checked this out this
is my announcer voice what's going on
everybody this is rob and today in this
video we're going to be discussing
the easter eggs of doctor strange 2
and so if this is of particular interest
to you
then make sure you like and subscribe uh
and
whatever else helps us succeed in the
algorithm
yeah this is uh this is my morning voice
so
yeah i don't know um people say they
love it
ah i don't know i've been listening to
it for a long time so let's talk about
uh let's talk about the easter eggs in
in doctor strange too let's kind of get
this out of the way first right and then
we'll get into the the spoiler review
segment so one thing to know we're not
doing these easter eggs in particular
order of when they appeared in the movie
we just noticed them but one of the cool
things here is the entire movie's plot
is a reference to loki which was
actually confirmed by kevin feige and
quoting here he said loki and sylvie did
something at the end of the series that
allowed all of this to be possible he
who remains is gone and that allowed a
spell to go wrong in spider-man no way
home which leads to the entire
multiverse going quite mad in this now
the funny thing about this is that uh
really there was only one reference to
the events of spider-man no way home and
it was basically doctor strange
explaining to america chavez the fact
that
that's their only real involvement in
the multiverse
but seemingly and as i understand it
there's been statements that have come
out from the creative side of doctor
strange too where they basically said
okay so like what took place in
spider-man no way home was because of
what happened in loki in terms of all
the multiversal madness and everything
the spell going wrong was actually due
to loki not really due to peter parker
and this really seems to fit that as
well that with the greater multiverse
out there now uh that seemingly this is
all done because of the events of loki
so a cool little moment there now the
other thing here the next little easter
egg we saw it's not really an easter egg
but it really is if you're if you're
familiar with comics is the book of
ashanti so if you're not familiar with
comics the book of ashanti is quite
literally what you're told in the movie
which is basically this book that is the
antithesis to the darkhold right if the
darkhold is a book of pure evil the
vishanti or the book of the vishanti is
a book of pure good in the comics it's a
lot more significant than that so in the
comics the book of ashanti is
is like the magical book right i mean it
really is in a lot of ways the
antithesis to the darkhold but like 80
of dr strange's power comes from the
triumvirate right comes from the
vishanti uh which are just these wildly
powerful magical beings the way in which
the role of the sorcerer supreme works
is that that person is chosen by the
vashanti right it's not a title that the
the the previous ancient one i'm sorry
the previous source or supreme can just
pass on to another person that what
happens is that whenever the sorcerer
supreme at that point in time dies their
essence or their soul or whatever you
want to call it goes into the ether
where basically it merges with the rest
of magical energy and existence when
that happens it triggers the
really the vashanti becoming aware of
the fact that the sorcerer supreme is
dead and a process is initiated whereby
a new source or supreme is chosen now
nine times out of ten it's usually the
disciple of the existing sorcerer
supreme for the same reason that people
date people in their social group
because you're socially vetted
people know you're legit it's basically
the same thing here right like the
vashanti don't necessarily or don't
usually just grab some rando out there
it's why uh stephen strange became the
the new source for supreme after the
passing of the ancient one because
stephen strange was the disciple of the
sorcerer supreme so it is cool right
it's not necessarily an absolute right
for every rule there's an exception to
the rule but the vashanti are hugely
powerful beings what this does is it
opens the doorway for presumably the
existence of the vashanti we don't
necessarily know if we'll see them but
to give you guys perspective here in
terms of how much power doctor strange
derives from them in the comics there
was a story where doctor strange refused
to fight on behalf of the vashanti in a
magical war so they stripped him of all
the power they provided which was like
80 of the power he had and then they
took away his role as sorcerer supreme
and gave it to a guy named jericho drum
also known as brother voodoo who ended
up becoming dr voodoo when he became the
new source for supreme ultimately of
course steven strange got the role back
and so on and so forth but that's the
kind of people that we're dealing with
here so it's a really cool little easter
egg if you're familiar with comics now a
really cool little moment is the whole
gargantos kaiju music that's playing in
the background it's a homage to the
godzilla monster movie archetype right
it's not necessarily the music of
godzilla not that i'm aware of although
it would have been cool if it was um i
doubt that disney has the rights to that
[Laughter]
but it would have been a cool little
thing right if it just been like the
music of uh of of uh godzilla there but
you know gargantos it's schuma gorham
but i'm gonna be honest with you guys
kind of an aside here i'm sort of glad
that wasn't really schumacher at the
meeting was gargantos but well it was
schumacher actually like organic here's
the thing shumogorath is not a being
that gets summoned right by like wanda
uh that does not happen shumagorath
conquers entire realities this guy's um
an absolute host there's whole universes
out there that have been enslaved by the
power of schuma gorath so he's he's way
up there he's not just a monster who is
summoned by wanda for the purpose of
tracking someone in the multiverse right
he's on a hound he's not a hound dog
that's not what he is uh so on one hand
it is cool to see what is in effect the
likeness of schuma gorath in the mcu but
after seeing the movie and seeing the
role it played i really hope it's not
actually schumachorath that like wanda
was aware of shumogorath or she saw an
image of shumogorath in the darkhold and
then copied its likeness and like that's
this being now but i really hope it's
not the actual schuma gorath because if
it is that would be hugely disappointing
uh but moving on one of the really cool
things that i loved about this and i'm
glad they kept it in was basically
america chavez's addiction uh from from
the comics right her addiction to pizza
here's the thing so in the comics
whenever america chavez travels from one
dimension to the next or uses any real
measure of her power she just she like
eats pizza in order to regain her energy
it's kind of her thing and it's cool
because like you'll have like these
random moments where i show user powers
and then like it'll just skip to her
eating pizza she'll be talking to people
but like she'll just be eating pizza
because it's the thing that she needs
right like she just addicted to it and
it's a cool thing i absolutely love it
because let's be honest with ourselves
we're all addicted to good pizza but the
next easter egg that i loved was
actually bruce campbell right
historically he's always appeared in sam
raimi movies for those of you guys who
are not familiar with that bruce
campbell and sam raimi are kind of like
the one-two punch of
really just the the kind of dark humor
comedic horror archetype and a lot of
that goes back to the days of the evil
dead right the evil dead was the movie
that put both bruce campbell and sam
remy on the map uh because it's it it's
it would be disingenuous to say it's got
a cult following i mean this transitions
way beyond just a cult following it
really is like it's it's a cultural film
right like it's a movie that just
defined that type of movie it's great
right now eventually it did give us uh
army of darkness which
depends on who you talk to but the evil
dead original is is really the best one
and so because of that bruce campbell
and sam raimi have just always gone hand
in hand and so it makes sense that you
would always see a bruce cam bruce
campbell uh cameo in a sam raimi movie
so that's why that's why you get that if
you guys never saw evil dead you should
go check it out be aware it's got some
crazy parts like when the chicks sitting
on the chair and like she gets possessed
because like they're doing the the card
game and the girls trying to pretend
like she can read minds and so the other
girl in the chair literally just starts
reading off all the cards and then she
turns around and her face is all screwed
up you know what i'm talking about like
it's just one of those really freaky
moments but uh yeah evil dead was a
great movie uh but but moving on on our
our of of easter eggs here the ultron
sentries now i loved this right i loved
this whole thing because there was a lot
of speculation in the early days of the
trailers and everything and rightfully
so because contextually it made sense
that it was basically the iron legion
right basically as it had been created
by uh by by tony stark iron man and it
was in effect not really ultron
centuries or anything predicated on
ultron beyond the fact that it was a
suit of armor around the world i did
love that these were modeled more in
line with ultra with ultron they were
just like the ultron sentry robots but
this is a great easter egg from the
events of ultron forever for those of
you guys who are familiar with that so
the idea behind ultron forever and it's
not an exact it's not an exact copy
again just more of an easter egg here in
ultron forever this was a story that was
originally teased i think and hickman's
avengers and new avengers god hickman's
vintage new events when captain america
was yanked what was okay what was it
guys those of you guys who read it
refresh my memory here
was it 500 years in the future i think
because first the the first time captain
america traveled when the time stone
first took him i want to say it was 50
years in the future
and then it was 500 years into the
future then there was a third stop and
that's when he realized that future
franklin richards was immortal right
which made sense he has the ability to
alter reality and then it was like 50
000 years in the future but whichever
time period it was essentially ultron
had conquered everything including
asgard and in fact ultron prime had
killed odin and then took the odin force
and sat on the throne of asgard as like
the all father right like all father
ultron it was nuts it was really really
cool
uh but this is like an easter egg to
that because it was ultron centuries
everywhere it's also a nice little
easter egg to the events of age of
ultron in the comics where ultron from
the future used vision as a vector to
send himself into the past and start
creating all these ultron robots to
conquer the world so that was cool right
just little little easter eggs right
both from the the marvel cinematic
universe itself right the suit around
like a suit of armor around the world
and then you know from the the actual
comics themselves which i absolutely
love the one thing i will say i'm a
little disappointed about is we didn't
actually get to see
iron man and i think the reason for that
i i'm not going to swear by this but i
want to say there was there was some
interview or something that i saw when
they were talking about that and they
were basically or maybe it was a tweet
maybe it was from matt ramos i don't
remember uh matt if you're watching this
video what's up so i think the whole
thing behind that is basically that like
reed richards was the one that basically
created the iron legion and actually got
it right uh as opposed to tony stark who
screwed it up and so it's it's a cool
little thing right i absolutely love
that little that little easter egg there
but the next one of course the
illuminati themselves now while this
doesn't seem like an easter egg as much
as like a like a point of the movie it
actually is an easter egg especially
with reed being a part of it so the
reason why is because again during this
this movie bar like one of the things to
know from the multiversal aspect this
movie borrowed heavily from jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers
that's why i say everybody should go
check out the videos that i have on
hickman's avengers new avengers and
secret wars from 2015. we'll have a link
in the description for it but you should
all go check it's a phenomenal story but
basically when the multiverse was
collapsing that reed richards had
constructed a bridge and what it would
do is it would allow him to see into the
multiverse technically the bridge
already existed he just adjusted it a
little bit but it allowed them to see
into the multiverse and so basically
they would take turns right so you would
have namor and black panther or you
would have reed or you'd have iron man
or something like that or beast hank
mccoy they would all basically just
watch the the bridge itself to see how
other realities were handling the the
incursion events to see if there was a
way to stop the incursions without
blowing up worlds and basically what you
ended up seeing were like these
alternate realities with different
versions of the illuminati so one group
might consist of magneto and professor x
and like captain america and i don't
know like iron man right maybe like a
few other people whereas one might be
composed of characters that
traditionally are villains but in that
reality they're all heroes so it would
really just like shift and change around
but i say that because while the
illuminati in this movie are aware of
the multiverse they are not a singular
entity in the multiverse it's not
there's only one illuminati american
child has stated that right she said
like every time you dream you will see
like alternate reality versions of
yourself and she said there's only one
of me in the entire multiverse now she's
only been to 72 different realities but
i figure like i feel like that's a big
enough sample size to know if there are
like if there are any universes out
there where only one person exists
across the whole multiverse you know
like if there's only one read she would
have figured that out if there was only
one professor x she would have figured
that out that kind of a thing but you
know basically it's this easter egg
pointing to the idea that the illuminati
is a universal concept meaning there is
an illuminati in every single universe
presumably in the main marvel cinematic
universe which we'll talk about here in
a second but the next easter egg that we
spotted was the baxter foundation now
the baxter foundation in terms of that
name does not exist in the comics that's
an easter egg in reference to the future
foundation now this is a really really
cool concept and i'm really hoping we
see it in the future of the marvel
cinematic universe so the way this
worked is you had what was called the
singularity conference or something like
that anyway it was a coming together
like the world scientists and what reed
richards had realized is that as far as
he was concerned the world scientists
were basically dumb they were limited in
their view and scope of all existence
which makes sense because reed's smarter
than basically all of them and so he's
able to look outside the box in a way
that scientists traditionally aren't
able to do because even among scientists
themselves they're rigid and structured
in their view of science and so what he
ended up doing was breaking away and
forming the future foundation under the
idea that the best people suited to come
up with ideas to solve the problems that
plague humanity and the present and in
the future are kids because they can
actually think outside the box they're
amazing at divergent thinking and so
because of that the future foundation
was a coming together of younger people
now obviously it's being changed around
a little bit because christine palmer is
not a kid right she's just part of the
baxter foundation so i do love that idea
from the maine marvel universe so they
took the future foundation and rolled it
over into this renamed it a little bit
but i'm hoping that in the future we
actually see the pure future foundation
of just younger people because on that
team you had like franklin and you had
valeria which those you guys who don't
know and we'll talk about them here in a
second they're hugely important uh but
there were some cool moments right it
was a cool little reference to the
future foundation itself but moving on
here of course professor x and the x-men
theme song which i absolutely adored oh
my god it was so great to see that uh
and to hear it right like as soon as i
heard that i was like oh my god i mean
we talked about that in the last video
that we did i absolutely adored it right
it was just it was something that i just
i had really been looking forward to and
i didn't know how much i needed it until
that video came out where that guy
basically redid the marvel intro but
with the x-men theme you know what i'm
talking about everybody's seeing that
video it was great i didn't realize how
much i needed that until we got it and i
have no doubt they're going to do that
with the x-men film in the mcu which i'm
just absolutely dying to see of course
we also got the yellow floating chair
you know i never really had anything
against xavier in the wheelchair but as
someone who who got into this whole geek
culture comic space because of x-men the
animated series way back in the 90s it
was just nice right it was just a nice
little nod to be able to see xavier now
here's one of the things that's kind of
cool if you sort of read between the
lines if xavier exists in in that
illuminati universe it would stand to
reason the x-men likely exist with him
so the question that i would ask here is
what was going on with the x-men in that
universe if we assume they exist are
they alive are they just training did
they die fighting thanos because a part
of me wants to believe it would have
been cool if they died fighting thanos
because that in and of itself would have
been an easter egg to uh to win avengers
new avengers when you had like the the
cabal of thanos right the black order
name or the submariner and those guys
when neymar started to realize that for
thanos and the black order it wasn't
just about destroying in cursive worlds
during the incursions it was about just
like killing everything on those worlds
and like a lust for death and
destruction but there was one point
where like they basically fought xavier
and they killed all of his x-men and
then or at least what was left of his
x-men the contingent that xavier sent
towards him uh towards thanos and them
and then they tortured xavier and forced
him to call the rest of the x-men so the
black water could kill all the other
x-men as well and then destroy the earth
it was a really really cool moment in
the in the comics but nonetheless right
it was it was a cool thing one of the
other things that i loved about this is
the xavier quote from the movie uh just
because someone stumbles and loses their
way does not mean they're lost forever
that's a quote from days of future past
so i love that they carry that over now
again there might be some theories that
come out about that right did xavier
always exist in the illuminati universe
was xavier plucked out of the days of
future past universe and brought here
and that's where he's basically been in
that reality ever since he's quite
literally out of time right is he out of
his own universe and in a new one
instead uh i mean i doubt that's the
case he's probably native to the
illuminati universe i don't really see a
reason why would be anything other than
that unless they just decide to change
it but it is a cool quote if anything it
would probably showcase the idea that
xavier in terms of personality is
basically exactly the same across the
whole multiverse maybe there's some evil
versions of xavier which i would
definitely want to see there's a what-if
story where professor x became the
juggernaut that was cool but uh beyond
that you know xavier is seemingly the
same everywhere but this goes into
probably one of the best easter eggs
here right which is susan storm franklin
richards and valeria richards now susan
storm here's the thing people sleep on
how powerful susan storm is you know
with her invisibility it's i mean
it speaks for itself right like i can't
see her
cool i guess but like when it comes to
her force fields that's a whole
different beast so like with with her
force fields like when she was fighting
the mad celestials she held off the
power of celestials right now granted
these celestials weren't looking to
destroy the world they were just looking
to destroy like sue and franklin and
reed and ben grimm and johnny and those
guys i mean if they wanted to they could
have obliterated the world which
probably would have killed sue and then
because she couldn't maintain her force
field forever and even if she did she
would have ran out of oxygen and they
would have suffocated and died so uh
she's not omnipotent
that's the point that i'm getting at but
her force fields are wildly capable now
valeria she is a wildly obscure
character and i would say you know
nothing about her if you've never read
the comics valeria is as smart as reid
and depending on what comic you're
reading she's actually smarter than reed
the valeria is the smartest person in
the world but it depends more recently
characters like uh like moon girl so
like lunella lafayette she's shown up
and she's like ridiculously intelligent
but uh but valeria is the daughter of
reed who is as smart as reed richards
and doctor doom she's an absolute genius
in fact she was the one that figured out
that the incursions couldn't be stopped
in avengers a new avengers and so she
literally sent a note to her dad and was
like you can't win it's time to figure
out how not to lose which was a really
really cool concept they ended up
figuring that out but nonetheless right
uh having sue and valeria is really
impressive in and of itself because
valeria is a member of the future
foundation which i would love to see in
the main mcu franklin is wildly powerful
and in fact it's been established
multiple times over the years in marvel
comics that with galactus being
basically a guy from a previous universe
that was reborn into the to the new
universe when it was created that that's
what will happen with galactus and
franklin that the the two of them will
be the last surviving beings in the
universe when it's destroyed when it
when it basically comes to its heat
death end right its natural end and that
they would end up merging into a more
powerful being that would be reborn in a
new in the new universe uh the
relationship between franklin and and
galactus is hugely significant right
it's a it's a very very cool
relationship between the two of them
just because of the level of power they
possess the kind of things that they can
do like the abraxas saga different
things like that it's a really really
cool thing so what we're talking about
here are wildly powerful and capable
beings that are just easter eggs that
are referenced i i don't think it's an
accidental thing i don't think it's an
accidental line i don't think it was
improved by john krasinski i think it
was written there intentionally because
we're going to see them in the future of
the mcu the real question is how badly
are they going to nerf franklin richards
because i feel like they're not going to
make him a character that can alter
reality on a universal scale however it
would be cool to see this you know
seven-year-old kid running around that
could basically do everything you saw
the celestials doing in the eternals
film
because he could it's cool but beyond
that one of the the coolest things about
this and this is what i loved that in
some ways the illuminati played the role
of the omniversal development court that
basically what you had here at least as
christina explained it to doctor strange
is that the numerical designation for
the marvel cinematic universe is earth
616. now a lot of people were kind of
baffled by that because they're like no
that's the numerical designation for
marvel comics but remember the marvel
comics multiverse and the marvel movies
multiverse are two separate multiverses
now they didn't used to be right
seemingly they weren't the same before
and that kind of seems to be what was
what was really going on is that the the
marvel cinematic universe had a
numerical designation in the in marvel
comics it was like one and then a bunch
of nines uh but what happened seemingly
what's taking place here is that where
the marvel cinematic universe multiverse
before the events of loki maybe was tied
into the comics or it was just something
that we as fans came up with that even
if that's the case that multiverse now
has been rejoined with the rest of the
movie multiverse so it's backwards
supposed to be and now it's part of that
whole multiverse there so basically
earth 616 is the main marvel cinematic
universe and er
616 is the main marvel comics universe
so it's cool to see that and it kind of
allows a little bit of crossover there
for no other reason than just based on
names but christine palmer in the
illuminati universe had basically said
like that's the numerical designation
that we've given to your your reality
now in marvel comics that was the
omniversal development court that did
that the omniversal magistrate saturnine
had actually explained that to captain
britain that like they gave the number
616 to the maine marvel universe it's
the first time in marvel comics that
universes are given a numerical
designation we didn't know that before
it was just an alternate reality where
stuff happened but once that numerical
designation was given that forever
became the standard number for the main
marvel uh marvel comics universe so
basically it's the mcu version of what
the omniversal development court did
it's a cool little easter egg right a
nice little reference there but moving
beyond that we get is we we really get
one of the coolest moments and i think
this is going to be a huge source of
debate among
comic fans and people who are fans of
the movies so if you guys recall we do
have that moment where wong and wanda
travel to wonder gore mountain now in
the comics this is a nice little easter
egg and a reference to the fact that
wonder gore is a location where wanda
was basically taken and raised by the
high evolutionary uh or at least for a
time until she was you know went off and
did her own thing but you also had that
place being the location where cathode
had basically been imprisoned at a
previous point in time or at least the
the portal that gives you access to his
dimension where he was in prison but a
portion of his essence is still there
which was gifted to wanda if you want to
call it a gift and that's how wanda
ended up gaining a portion of chaos
magic or the ability to manipulate chaos
magic was because of her time in
wondergore mountain and being touched by
catholic so what this does is right off
the bat this tells me like as soon as i
saw that when wong was like you know the
the dark hole as you had it was
basically a copy the original texts are
written here by the first demon to ever
practice dark magic i was immediately
like c'thun that's exactly who that is
but a part of me also wants to believe
there'd be a little bit of fan service
in the sense that in that moment when or
at least near the end of the movie when
america chavez had basically opened the
portal and was gonna push wanda through
and it had like the hellish dimension on
the other side that looked like the
realm of mephisto so i think it'd be
cool if there was a bit of crossover
between the two because technically
speaking the realm of catholic is called
the flickering realm and i don't see i
didn't see that realm like changing
right like the flickering realm is such
that like it changes all the time so it
could look really really snowy and then
in the blink of an eye it would look
like hell it would just fluctuate and
then it might be really really lush and
green and it would just change all the
time i didn't see that there like it
maintained the same look from the time
the portal was open until seemingly the
time the portal closed although i'm not
100 sure if that portal ever closed uh
maybe it did i don't remember off top of
my head but regardless that looked like
the realm of mephisto and i feel like it
would have been a really cool thing if
basically the the marvel cinematic
universe took the concept of mephisto
and merged it with the concept of
cathode and basically goes from there so
like those individuals who manipulate
the dark hole that's cathode slash
mephisto corrupting you and then
ultimately he'll steal your soul if
enough time passes or he'll take it from
you or whatever the case happens to be
but it was a cool little thing right now
moving beyond that of course we got some
some cool little moments i guess i guess
it's cool we got anson mount as black
bolt i don't know black bolt is a
character always sucks so it doesn't
matter to me uh but of course peggy
carter had the reference that she can do
this all day which i think we were all
kind of hoping she would say right you
know i thought it was cool like as soon
as she said that i was like yes
[Laughter]
so that was nice to see um kind of an
obscure easter egg that we spotted here
wanda's entrance in camartage when she
was showing herself in the reflections
and then finally came through the mirror
uh that was reminiscent of the ring
which i absolutely loved because the
ring of course basically being uh being
that little girl who was seemingly pure
evil and was like killing people
in turn wanda kind of manifests in the
same way so sort of mirroring that
horror element which is one of the
things i love about sam raimi is he
borrows from like other horror genres
that were iconic in some form or fashion
and then of course we got the heads of
the living tribunals now the the head of
the living tribunal was cool because
seemingly that's this is maybe where the
statue statue had came from in loki uh
when all that stuff was just being
teleported to you know the end of all
things right where uh where the he who
remains basically resided that was cool
i don't really know what the
significance is because of course they
weren't just random statue heads their
eyes were lit up so i don't know if that
if the living tribunal as we know him
actually exists or if it's just a realm
of living tribunal heads i have no idea
what to make of that because there's
only one living tribunal across the
whole multiverse in uh in marvel comics
so maybe with the marvel cinematic
universe being its own multiverse things
are different there and there's a living
tribunal in every universe who resides
or presides over that universe and
that's basically it i have no clue how
this works let me know what you guys
think down in the comments i want to
know your theories on the whole living
tribunal thing but yeah you know it was
it was cool of course at the end of the
movie we got clea we'll do a movie of do
a video about her separately because i
think that's a that's a pretty
significant thing i'll also do a video
on comics explain explaining clea right
i imagine people are going to be
interested in that mobile comics clia
explained people are going to want that
um that's probably going to go up on
maybe monday or tuesday i mean i usually
give it like the first weekend when it
comes to a movie this big uh if you
didn't see it in the first weekend
there's a good chance you're probably
not going to see it for a little while
anybody who was in that much of a rush
and wanted to avoid spoilers that bad
will have seen the movie over the course
of this weekend so uh yeah after the
weekend all bets are off but uh
nonetheless you know it's it's cool the
movie was great i absolutely loved it i
i had a blast watching this whole thing
so because we're running up on 30
minutes here uh we'll do the spoiler
review in a different video uh because i
didn't realize it was going to take us
this long to cover all these easter eggs
so
we'll do the spoiler review in a
separate video and uh yeah i will catch
you all later
peace